welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to
when Toy Story 4 was first announced
many labelled it as an unnecessary
sequel to a film franchise that wrapped
up perfectly with its third outing
however the film definitely deserves
your attention and while seeing things
like forky and the trailers may have put
some viewers off I'm pleased to say that
the movie is highly enjoyable from
beginning to end
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the film as well as what I took
from its ending this is full spoilers
ahead so if you don't want to know
anything about the movie then I highly
suggest that you turn it off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for click in this video I hope you
enjoy it
now sit back relax and let's get into my
breakdown of Toy Story 4 the film opens
in 2010 with Ann Lee playing with the
toys and weari watch as he grows up in
an amazing introduction that acts as the
perfect recap of the franchise it also
beautifully sets up the aesthetic of the
piece which is about losing your purpose
due to things around you that you are
unable to control the changing Woody has
been the head of the franchise since it
first began back in 1995 however Toy
Story 4 picks up with him pretty much
relegated to the back seat with little
attention being paid to him and this
removes his purpose in life
woody was created to be loved and to
love back however with no one playing
with him he really feels like he's lost
his meaningful life and goes around
micromanaging all of the other toys to
me this is a metaphor for retirement and
how often we look upon seniors and such
as having lost their purposefulness old
people have often lived vibrant lives
however in their winter years they may
feel neglected and forgotten about this
is the position that would he finds
himself in but rather than being a
nostalgic look at the past and the quote
unquote good old days Toy Story 4 is
more about regaining one's love for life
and finding a reason
go on what'ii though not in the
limelight still wishes to make sure pani
is happy and he facilitates this until a
spanner or rather fork is thrown into
the works with the creation of four key
a handmade toy that comes to life after
becoming lost on a road trip what he
makes it his goal to track down four key
and return him to body purely because
you know that will make her happy along
the way what do you rediscovers bo-peep
and she along with several other toys
have decided to move on and live their
whole lives when he realizes that they
are worlds apart now in terms of what
they want from life and it makes woody
question whether he is really doing the
right thing enough in the end what he
saves the day and the majority of the
plot wraps up much as you'd expect
however the movie then diverts away from
the norm with the toys being reunited to
show that woody has moved on to the next
stage of his life he has discovered new
meaning and says goodbye to the group
going off with Bo Peep to try and find a
new purpose for toys that may have lost
their way similar to how he did what he
just wants what's best for the world and
this new quest to find happiness for
others at the expense of his own gives
him a reason to go on it's a
heartbreaking moment especially if he
follows the franchise since 1995 but it
also shows that life is full of ups and
downs and that nothing lasts forever and
that we must all go our own way find our
own meaning and reason to go on we are
all carving out our own paths and will
lose and gain people along the way but
overall our life is ultimately about
what we do and what we make of it
Toy Story 4 is about discovering for
ourselves or the good we can do even
when it seems like we have no reason to
be here to me this is cemented by the
newly created character coming in and
asking why they exist and the answer
that is given to it is I don't know we
have all been put on this planet for one
reason or another but at the core of it
we don't really know why and life is
about setting out and finding a purpose
that not only means a lot to us but also
others overall it's a really powerful
message that definitely sticks with you
and whilst I probably still don't know
whether we needed to go back at this
universe this sequel still pulls it off
in an outstanding
fashion but what did I think about it
overall well whilst I did really enjoy
the film I think it falls slightly
behind the other three in the franchise
that's not to say it's bad though and
Toy Story 4 still does an incredible job
at character building animation and
drama
it's just they set an extremely high bar
with the first three films and then the
last one closed the chapter on these
characters perfectly this is still the
perfect add-on if you'd like to see more
adventures it doesn't feel like required
watching if you're already happy with
how the original trilogy ended but this
delivers on the promise of telling an
intriguing story so in the end Toy Story
4 is enjoyable from beginning to end and
it gets an 8.5 out of 10
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film and what you took from it
and make sure you let me know if you
agree with my score or not comment below
and let me know and if you enjoy this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my breakdown of the leaked
Joker plot which would be linked at the
end it covers all of the new details and
outlines of the story so it's definitely
worth checking out after this which are
linked at the end this is the channel
for people who were mad into movies so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]